je vais pas rester longtemps
je réponds qu'on a compris l'alanine sûr
c'est qu'ils soient sur la fierté est
neuf c'est de changer homicide de
changer assassinat par monsieur jean
edmé claire utilise le mot d'homicide il
propose à bernard en rester là mais si
procès il ya sera une belle occasion
parler de revenir sur ce drame
en vérité la mort d'amy fraises qu'il
faut pas oublier qui est un jeune homme
combat pour la défense de l'écologie est
un jeune pacifique
et que sa mort est un drame voilà moi je
crois que génération j'ai 48 ans j'ai
commencé à militer quand on m'a dit que
c'est qu'ils n'avaient perdu la vie la
démission se passe quoi qui était
ministre de l'intérieur ça nous semblait
logique et nos sud de vaquer qui était
intensément soeur avait démissionné
voilà ça se faisait à l'époque on nous
c'est ce qu'on a dit quand elle ferait
ses grandes il ya un responsable
l'avenant
c'est l'occasion d'en reparler s'il le
faut mais avec ce mot et le gendarme
qualifié d'assassin non mais je crois
que les choses clairement c'est la
chaîne de responsabilités que nous
pointons est en haut de cette chaîne
responsabilité d'un ministre après il ya
des hommes qui ont été exécutés par des
gens ne nous ne ciblons pas les gens qui
ont exécuté des heures nous voulons
d'abord faire la lumière sur la chaîne
arrêt spécial ici les gendarmes
aujourd'hui la famille aussi de rémy
fraysse évident à ses blessés donc c'est
pas ça que j'ai envie de commenter je
répète qu'il ya eu des responsables
politiques d ordonner le matériel
utilisé qui seraient disproportionnées
différents rappels de personnalités sur
place et non des moindres qui ont
interpellé le préfet pour dire attention
tout ça hatem est un enchaînement
malheureux qui a produit ce drame
terrible voilà ce que nous disons nez
tranquillement aussi monsieur est d'un
peu que nous reparlions de se pousser de
deux pardon de ce drame et bien jean luc
mélenchon ne se défilera pas et sans
l'occasion que tout le monde vienne à la
barre les témoins les journalistes et
que nous puissions pour faire la lumière
sur ce drame affreux fait ça servira non
gérés complets assassinat je réponds ce
que disait jean luc à leur genre du
plongeon s'agit d'un homicide
voilà la formulation
nous utilisons aujourd'hui pour pourra
en rester là mais si je suis au cazenobe
aller devant les tribunaux et bien jean
dufaux long comme connaissez tous ne se
défilera pas parce qu'une pédagogie à ce
débat et je crois c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est que beaucoup de gens
qui ont manifesté contre la loi y
compris ont pu parfois il y avait des
consignes de fermeté d'attitude de la
part des forces de l'ordre l'encore qui
exécutaient des angles il ya eu pourtant
la technique des nations des
manifestants était bloqué et c'est donc
on souhaite que le droit de manifester
soit respectée et qu' il n'y ait pas des
choses qui puisse amener ou lorsqu'on
est manifestants jambières père de
famille alors que ses enfants
manifestent à se dire est ce que ça va
mal tourner voilà donc ce sera
l'occasion s'il nous faut mais
franchement on veut parler de l'élection
législative qui viennent le code du
travail ça nous concerne tous la
suppression de 127 postes de
fonctionnaires annoncé par monsieur
l'info ça nous concerne tous
le nécessaire politique écologique c'est
ça qui est important c'est ça notre
programme mélenchon il lance sa campagne
mais je vais pas répondre cardiff
[Musique]
le père de la nation
je vais être honnête avec vous je suis
comme jean luc mélenchon les affaires
sans ton lit en lui et votre travail
c'est normal qu'il y ait un travail qui
sera fait et c'est clair que c'est assez
malheureux s'apercevoir que l'homme le
plus important nous marchons tous dans
une affaire qui courent on la découpe de
l'âme est assez curieuse donc on va voir
mary jane une proposition qui est que
ceux qui sont juste là des comportements
là qui sont peu vertueux et moi je pense
que c'est peu vertueux ça correspond pas
à des codes éthiques que j'entends
respecter
il ya le bulletin de vote peut régler
assez rapidement cette affaire voilà
donc quand les conditions qu'il ya un
changement de gouvernement évidemment ce
que nous proposons c'est un gouvernement
autour des propositions d'un france en
soumise avec les députés qui sont
l'espère le plus possible la circulation
pour le deuxième tour
pensez à des investissements se rendent
en cas de triangulaire comme
on analysera tout ça au soir du premier
tour à ce stade attitude qui est la
mienne et celle une force qui se veut
bon dirais-je conquérante terre des
grandes ambitions qui abordent cette
élection en concédant qu'il est possible
que nous soyons présents dont la 10 78%
peut-être des circonscriptions donc
c'est ça d'abord et avant tout puis on
verra le résultat on analysera la
situation et c'est clair qu'on fasse
autonome qui entend avoir le plus d'élus
possible c'est possible et c'est dans
cet état d'esprit à la veille du premier
tour que quel que j'aborde j'aborde
cette campagne et on veut parler du fond
on veut parler du fond ce qui intéresse
les français et des fins de mois
difficiles nous propose en augmenter le
smig nous pourrons une fois de plus ce
qui est des rêves une réforme fiscale
nous prenons lutter contre la fraude et
l'évasion fiscale 60 à 80 milliards
d'euros chaque année quand on voit ya
beaucoup de sujets de fond que les gens
dont les gens nous parlent et qu'ils
sont et sont d'éviter d'être sur des
parfois des polémiques secondaire qui
occupe beaucoup de temps mais qui
correspond pas aux préoccupations de nos
concitoyens
justement ces sujets ils vous ont pas
permis d'être au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle pourquoi
est-ce que vous pensez que maintenant
ils vous permettrait d'aller au second
tour de l'élection législative et de
remporter un siège
je fais moi c'est peut-être la chaleur
de quels sujets vous pardon on en était
à 19 58 % on a fait on a fait un premier
don merveilleux faut le dire moi comme
toujours un jeune homme de passion
j'étais triste au soir du premier tour
parce qu'on s'est dit c'est pas passé
loin mais tout de même
gardons en tête que ce qu'on a réalisé
un score incroyable c'était une campagne
magnifique c'est un formidable succès il
ya aujourd'hui encore plus de gens que
lors de la campagne présidentielle et
croyez moi qui s'engage dans la campagne
législative de nous sommes en dynamique
il ya rien à regretter
ou alors plein de chose à regretter par
définition mais on n'a pas du tout à
rougir
de ce qu'on a fait et je crois que les
thématiques en apporter qui sont celles
de la justice sociales qui sont celles
de la nécessaire exigences de de la
règle vert c'est à dire qu'il n'y ait
pas un système productiviste qui
continue et qui remettent en cause la
planète elle-même de l'exigeant de
droits nouveaux pour les citoyens à
travers la 6ème république c'est des
thèmes très présents aujourd'hui dans le
débat public et ça moi je suis très fier
qu'on ait réussi à faire ça donc on
continue c'est ce que d'ailleurs nous
demandent les gens les journées qu'ils
veulent on parle du fond et jean luc
mélenchon a évoqué notamment
c'est lorsqu'il est venu à montrer pour
m'aider lors d'un meeting je voulais
arrêter parler d'école du travail de la
nécessaire défense du code du travail
c'est ça que veulent les gens et qu'on
doit continuer à faire dans les jours
qui nous restent à vendre mais justement
vous vouliez vous voulez parler du fond
vous l'avez dit on voit que cette
affaire 15,9 ça pollue complètement le
débat est ce que les solutions ça serait
pas tout simplement s'excuser plutôt que
de remettre une clé dans la machine j'en
ai ya l'effet loupe des médias je ne
critique pas votre travail mais observer
quand le politique anti fait dans une
semaine 12 discours sur des sujets
sociaux rien n'accroche alors passer par
l'augmentation de la csg que propose
monsieur mâcon la remise en cause du
code du travail nous concerne tous tout
ce qui nourrit la y aurait de quoi faire
des enquêtes donner la parole comme on
irait jeu
souligner ce que nous disons pour vous
qu'on fait qu'on puisse en débattre la
presse fait le choix de mettre un coup
de loupe sur ses déclarations
moi je ne trouve pas ça adapté après là
encore comme c'est ça touche un sujet
qui est une question sensible la faire
ré mi fa est et sur lequel nous
n'entendons pas nous défiler parce que
beaucoup d'acteurs et de cette situation
de 2,2 de ce drame de gens qui ont été
touchés là dedans veulent que le fait
qu'ils ont toute la clarté puis cette
fête il faut qui est en procès faisons
mais jean-luc l'ancien a dit c'est le
terme homicide qui l'utilisé je répète
c'est moi il propose à monsieur cazenave
d'en rester là ce monsieur cazeneuve
veut qu'il y ait ce procès le procès
aura lieu et il y aura peut-être
d'ailleurs une vertu à ce procès
l'occasion de parler de quelle est la
chaîne de responsabilité là dedans et
nous pensons nous c'est notre conception
républicaine que quand on a l'honneur
d'être ministre de l'intérieur est en
poste très important mais on porte une
responsabilité quand
là il ya un drame qui en plus tous ceux
qui ont enquêté le savent il ya eu quand
même beaucoup de signal d'alerté ont été
tirées des méthodes peu adapté des
consignes données qui faisait courir un
risque donc au bout d'un moment on ne
peut pas seulement et nous c'est pas
d'autre qu'à dire c'est la faute aux
gendarmes
c'est qu'ils sont les responsables
locaux de la chaîne de responsabilités
il ya un homme s'était business de
l'intérieur qui s'avère être à ce moment
là monsieur casnav donc c'est pourquoi
quand monsieur casseneuil nous attaquer
c'est d'abord lui qui commence en
parlant non du flétrissant considérant
que nous n'aurions pas pris nos
responsabilités face à l'ex en boîte ce
qui est erroné
bien entendu on va dire plusieurs fois
pas une voix pour le front national nous
l'avons dit répété pourquoi travestir la
réalité puisque 15 9
montré du doigt ou utiliser ce terrain
là il ya une réponse qu'elle était faite
qui me semble être une réponse
pertinente
une belle lutte politique avec l'ue en
ce sens je viens boire et danser un
socialiste c'est une revanche et leur
entourage
bonjour bonjour bon je profite de mon du
fait de le suivre à paris et pas à
marseille vous pour ce point de presse
pour me présenter devant vous et faire
ce point que font traditionnellement mes
amis qui dirige eux de manière
opérationnelle la campagne des
législatives ce que comme vous savez on
a changé notre dispositif une bonne
partie de ceux qui organisaient la
campagne présidentielle étant devenus
des candidats aux législatives
il a fallu adapter les responsabilités
les prises de responsabilités alors nous
sommes maintenant à quinze jours du
premier tour les horoscope sondages dont
nous sommes saisis nous placent en
situation d'être présent au deuxième
tour dans de très nombreuses
circonscriptions du pays sans qu'on
puisse évaluer ce chiffre avec certitude
pas en tout cas dans de très nombreuses
circonscriptions au demeurant il y avait
un calcul simple à faire si nos
électeurs de l'élection présidentielle
se présentait de nouveau pour voter pour
le même programme représentait
évidemment par des candidats différents
à l'élection législative nous avions
calculé que nous serions présents dans
78% des circonscriptions au 2e tour ont
naturellement une telle décale que ne se
fait pas mécaniquement et on ne s'attend
pas à une telle proportion cependant
voilà de ce que nous savons les choses
se présentent bien au demeurant il ya
aussi ce que nous observons sur le
terrain
sans doute est-ce le résultat du fait
que d'une façon ou d'une autre
beaucoup de nos électeurs comme ceux
d'ailleurs d'autres d'autres formations
ont eu le sentiment de se faire voler un
peu l'élection présidentielle dans la
mesure où un temps considérable dans
cette élection a été consacrée à des
sujets qu'il n'avait rien à voir avec
les programmes ça a été les costumes de
monsieur fillon puis ensuite les emplois
puis ceux ci puissent là bref il ya eu
beaucoup de difficulté à faire entendre
des comparatifs de programme même si il
ya eu des débats télévisés assez utile
mais qui du fait même de leur
configuration rendait assez difficile
l'approfondissement de la discussion sur
les points du programme ans il ya dans
le pays le sentiment que cette élection
s'est passé bizarrement et qu'elle s'est
achevée par une sorte de vote contraint
et forcé par ailleurs baptisée front
républicain qui fait que en définitive
une importante king étant candidat
contre madame le pen subi immédiatement
la jonction enfin est portée contre
quelque sorte madame le pen ne sert
strictement à rien sinon qu'à être cette
deuxième mâchoire du piège à tuer les
débats politiques
bon ça fait que sur le terrain il y a un
certain sentiment de revanche
on va dire et nous on constate une une
belle mobilisation autour de nous qui ne
se dément pas d'une semaine sur l'autre
et c'est à ça que j'attribue le fait que
en prévision de ces deuxième tour qui
nous confond très très souvent soit au
front national puisque nous sommes les
seuls à les faire reculer à faire
reculer le front national soit à des
candidats
macro nist il y as contre nous un tir de
barrage qui reprend les anciennes
principal et les méthodes dégoûtante de
la dernière période de l'élection
présidentielle et de l'entre-deux tours
c'est à dire ce sont des incriminations
personnel d'une violence toujours plus
grande qui concerne aussi bien nos
concurrents après tout pourquoi pas mais
aussi et de manière assez surprenante un
certain nombre de médias craintes qui se
sont fait une spécialité de nous
insulter de nous invectiver
apparemment tout le monde s'y met c'est
un grand exercice de mélenchon bashing
ainsi que de tout ce qui de près ou de
loin mme approche
bon ceci se fait je pense comme plutôt
un exercice de fortification du pouvoir
mac rognant qui n'est pas si stable
qu'il en a l'air il faut qu'on déploie
beaucoup d'énergie à en faire l'apologie
quotidienne avec ici et là des scènes
tout à fait émouvante d'adulation
médiatique car en vérité ce que les
mêmes sondages nous montre c'est que
moins d'un français sur deux souhaite
que le président est une majorité
absolue à l'assemblée et s'il en est
ainsi c'est parce que tout le monde a
bien compris que cet homme dans sa
définition du pouvoir qui la qualifie
lui-même de jupitérien représente une
forme de surf suprême de l'autorité
personnelle dans la république et que ça
nous semble être très imprudent de
confier autant de pouvoirs à une
personne aussi halluciné de d'elle-même
alors bon plusieurs choses après je me
prêterait volontiers à vos questions la
première c'est que nous croyons qu'il
faut que dans cette élection on puisse
discuter des thèmes qui vont être
l'actualité sociale et politique qui
suivront immédiatement les élections
législatives
en effet comme vous le savez nous nous
présentons non pas comme une force de
témoignage mais comme une force
d'alternative c'est à dire que nous
entrons dans l'élection législative en
proposant aux gens de nous confier la
majorité pour vous
le pays on pense qu'on le dit à
l'ambition on doit pas très bien quelle
autre ambition pourrait avoir quand on
entre dans une élection que de les
gagner et il nous semble important que
chacun comprenne bien que ce n'est pas
une affaire de personne de savoir si on
va faire plaisir aux petits princes
aussi vont on ne va pas lui faire
plaisir que se prépare-t-il le président
l'a lui-même annoncé sa première
préoccupation ce n'est ni le changement
climatique ni la misère dans le pays ni
aucun de ces problèmes c'est le code du
travail
cette obsession est en soi une signature
elle montre que le pays se prépare ce il
s'abandonne à monsieur macron entrer
dans une nouvelle phase de dérégulation
dont tout indique qu'elle devrait être
extrêmement féroce pourquoi parce que la
loi elle comrie entre seulement en
application et cette loi prévoit déjà
des éléments de dérégulation extrêmement
profond par exemple c'est la négociation
par entreprise du temps de travail il ya
donc rien qui interdit de penser et
d'ailleurs le président l'a dit lui même
que d'autres questions touchant
l'organisation du travail pourraient à
leur tour entrer dans ce champ de la
soi-disant négociation entreprise par
entreprise comme naturellement la
question des salaires comme la question
de la durée du travail quotidiennes ou
hebdomadaires etc etc etc
donc c'est un choc extrêmement violent
qui se prépare ensuite sur le plan du de
l'économie et de la possibilité pour les
milieux populaires de trouver leur
compte à la nouvelle situation nous
voulons faire remarquer et insisté pour
qu'on puisse discuter du fait que le
président a prévu de demander la
suppression des cotisations maladie et
chômage et leur remplacement par une
augmentation de la csg
je peux je demande pourquoi est il
impossible de discuter de cette question
et du résultat qu'elle aura et je veux
en signalé au moins deux le premier
c'est la ponction que cela représente
sur la consommation populaire alors
qu'il éprouvait dans toute l'europe que
c'est cette consommation qui est le
vecteur
le plus puissant du développement de
l'activité il n'y a pas de contre
exemple sur ce point et bien cette
augmentation de la csg revient à une
ponction de 20 milliards d'euros sur
l'économie et sur la consommation
populaire
j'ai ainsi sur ce chiffre c'est
davantage que ce que prévoyait monsieur
fillon et que son augmentation de la tva
enfin si pour les travailleurs du
secteur privé
le transfert après c et g de ses
cotisations du salaire brut vers le
salaire net représentera une légère
augmentation qui pourrait parfaitement
être immédiatement absorbé par l'impôt
pour tous les autres salariés je veux
dire ceux du secteur public aussi bien
dans la fonction publique territoriale
que dans la fonction publique d'état et
pour les retraités cela représente une
ponction pure et simple que nous avons
évalué pour un revenu de 1200 euros
mensuels à 250 euros annuels de fonction
il s'agit donc d'une somme tout à fait
considérable a rapporté au salaire des
personnes concernées or il semble qu'on
ne peut pas parler de ce point on ne
cette question n'est pas dans le débat
est le elle n'intéresse pas comme a eu
un intéressé en son temps si vous vous
en souvenez c'est à dire en 2002
la question de la cs de l'âme de la tva
sociale qui avaient été soulevés et qui
avait été le coeur du débat du des
législatives de cette année alors on ne
parle pas de ça on ne sait pas pourquoi
et évidemment nous on souhaiterait qu'on
en parle j'ai pris là de deux exemples
qui montrent que nous nous dirigeons
vers un choc social d'une violence
extrême et que tout se passe comme si
nous vivions dans un conte de fées où un
personnage
comme l'a dit un hebdomadaire séduit le
monde parce que il n'ya pas de
dithyrambes c'est assez puissante
semble-t-il pour qualifier l'action du
nouveau chef de l'état ce qui pousse
aussi à l'inquiétude c'est la façon avec
laquelle se constitue non seulement le
gouvernement cela déjà vous l'avez
observé mais également les cabinets
ministériels
il y a quelque chose de quasi quotidiens
dans cette manière de s'entourer des
représentants de tous les oligarques du
pays puisque on retrouve alors comme
premier ministre le porte parole du
lobby nucléaire comme directeur de
cabinet de tel ministre l'ancien
directeur adjoint du medef comme
lobbyiste chargé de l'accompagnement des
politiques agricoles telles personnes
qui s'occupaient de la même tâche au
profit de dandé dans des lobbys le lobby
du genre en l'occurrence etc etc
tout jeu on a pointé quelques unes de
ces choses dans le dossier de presse que
nous vous remettons et pour nous il y as
danger à voir se concentrer dans un
système institutionnel qui déjà font
centre temps de pouvoir sur la
présidence tant de personnes qui sont
directement liés aux grands lobbys du
pays et qui parfois les personnes étant
celle qui était chargé des relations
publiques de ces de ces grandes
entreprises
vous avez vu vous même à connaître de la
décision du chef de l'état de choisir
qui serait autorisé à l'accompagner dans
ses différents déplacements organisant
ainsi lui même l'action des médias tout
ça on l'a connu ailleurs mais ce n'est
pas parce que c'est fait avec le sourire
avec grâce que nous oublions quelle est
la signification profonde de cette
manière de vouloir tout contrôler et
contrôler tout le monde est d'établir un
lien très direct avec les milieux des
affaires
évidemment comme on sait qu'on va avoir
les ordonnances tous s'adonnent à ce
début une connotation que nous trouvons
nous très malsaine et nous voulons le
dire avec beaucoup de force
j'ajoute que nous avons très mal reçu
les premières affirmations celle de
monsieur castaner selon lequel dans
l'hypothèse
matheron gagnerait on n'aurait pas le
droit de bloquer le pays comme il dit
c'est à dire d'avoir une action sociale
qui participent finalement des formes
assez traditionnelles de la démocratie
sociale dans ce pays
je rappelle qu'une élection n'éteint pas
le débat dans un pays ce n'est pas un
blanc seing et ce n'est pas un mandat
dictatorial que l'on donne à celui qui a
gagné c'est une autorité et le pouvoir
d'exercer un mandat le mandat impératif
en toute hypothèse n'existe pas dans
notre pays
prolonger l'état d'urgence déjà en soi
pose problème mais vouloir transférer le
contenu de l'état d'urgence dans le
droit commun du pays est une grave
erreur et entraîne notre système
juridique sur une pente sur laquelle
nous ne voulons pas le voir aller voilà
monsieur maquereau et le président des
riches et ils s'entourent de leurs
commensaux il le prépare une grande fête
pour l'oligarchie et c'est le peuple qui
va la payer
il est dur avec les nôtres et doux avec
les autres voilà ce qui se dessine dans
ses premiers pas de gouvernance du pays
alors encore un mot ou plus exactement 2
le premier sera pour évoquer la
rencontre avec monsieur poutine je fais
remarquer que le coeur des indignés
traumatisé kim accusé d'angélisme
lorsque je disais qu'il fallait discuter
avec la russie plutôt que d'organiser un
blocus et une montée en puissance d'un
retour insensé aux méthodes de la guerre
froide que il valait mieux discuter
plutôt que de déployer des troupes comme
sont en train de le faire à l'otan eh
bien c'est exactement ce que fait le
président macron ils discutent et pour
la syrie il a ouvert le choix de cette
hypothèse que j'évoquais devant vous qui
m'avez lu de l'époque d'être traités là
aussi dans génique ou d'hommes qui
n'avaient pas sens des réalités
je n'aurai pas la cruauté de rappeler
qui parmi vous a publié comme titre que
les conditions n'a fait c'était en syrie
c'était la paix de moto avec une photo
de votre serviteur avec un petit bras
d'olivier tandis que là on célèbre le
dialogue de monsieur macron avec que
monsieur poutine j'espère que ceux qui
signait ses papiers seront reconnaître
que j'avais eu raison avant tout le
monde sur ces sujets pour ma part je
n'aurais pas organisé
une telle comment dire démonstration que
celle qui a été fait à versailles en
effet s'il ne s'agit pas d'aller dans
l'escaladé avec la russie on ne peut pas
non plus considérer est passé à perte et
profit tous les événements qui ont eu
lieu récemment et notamment ce viol yeux
en crimée je pense que aussi longtemps
qu'on n'a pas retrouvé les conditions
d'un règlement harmonieux des questions
de la paix et de la guerre et des
tensions qui existent sur les frontières
une certaine réserve même si il doit y
avoir de l'engagement très profond dans
le dialogue une certaine réserve est de
mise voilà alors dans les dernières
heures on me cherche poule sur toutes
sortes de choses
ce matin je me fais traiter de
complotiste sur france inter sur ces
news monsieur jean françois kahn m'a
traitée de doriot je crois est ainsi de
suivre ce sont naturellement des paroles
pleines de douceur et d'intelligence
tandis que ma remarque qui a duré une
seconde écart puisque nous avons regardé
dans un discours de trois quarts d'heure
c'était le 11e que je prononçais dans la
même semaine concernant monsieur 15,9 me
vaut maintenant évidemment toutes sortes
de monter aux rideaux et de manière de
me montrer du doigt il faut dire que
vraiment cette semaine ça a battu tous
les records de mélenchon bashing ça a
commencé par un article absolument
infâme qui se moque de nos morts et de
nourriture elle alors que d'habitude on
respecte au moins ça dans le magazine du
monde et ça se poursuit maintenant à la
cadence quotidienne d'une invective
contre moi considéré comme une figure
normal alors si vous voulez on évoquera
cette question de monsieur 15,9 parce
qu'elle a intéressé mais je veux vous
dire que personnellement je n'y attache
aucun intérêt j'attache de l'intérêt à
la sphère de rémy france pas monsieur
cazeneuve et j'ai évoqué je voudrais le
rappeler je n'ai évoqué cet épisode de
la responsabilité administrative d'un
ministre qui est le chef de son
administration est donc responsable des
actes des fonctionnaires qui le qu'il
mette en mouvement que parce que
lui-même m'avait dit que j'avais refusé
de
prononcée contre l'extrême droite ce qui
n'a pas retenu votre attention lorsque
vous avez évoqué la prise de position de
monsieur cazeneuve à mon encontre le
point de départ c'est qu'il a dit que je
ne mettais pas exprimés contre le front
national laissant entendre que en
quelque sorte une lan tiennent
dorénavant a répandu dans tout le parti
socialiste et bien il y aurait une
certaine ambiguïté de notre comportement
il considère que la consigne pas une
voix pour me dont madame le pen n'est
pas une consigne assez clair en effet ce
que tous veulent c'est connu fassions
allégeance comme lui-même l'a fait
monsieur macron monsieur 15,9 à monsieur
matheron et voilà ce que nous ne voulons
pas faire et ne feront jamais voilà
alors en effet dans un discours de trois
quarts d'heure pendant une seconde
d'écart
j'ai évoqué l'homicide qui a conduit à
la mort de monsieur rémy frais je tiens
à rappeler que le furet me ferais ce
n'est pas mort dans un accident de
voiture et qu'il n'est pas tombé d'un
train il a reçu une grenade offensive et
l'utilisation de ce matériel est un
problème qui à l'époque a été soulevée
par de très nombreux observateurs ce
qu'ils veulent en connaître et en savoir
davantage je les renvoie tous à l'
enquête qui avait été fait par un de vos
confrères en l'occurrence reporter qui
avait travaillé ce sujet très à fond je
rappelle que nous avons parmi nos
candidats dans la haute garonne
l'avocate des des personnes qui ont été
interpellés qui ont été inculpés sur le
site de siemens ainsi que de la famille
durée vie fraysse et bien dans ces
conditions j'estime qu'il est normal de
ma part moi qui avais demandé la
démission de monsieur 15,9 à cette
occasion comme j'avais pu observer
compte tenu du nombre des événements
auxquels j'ai été impliqué dans ma vie
militante que lorsque
malik oussékine avaient été tués à la
suite d'une charge de motocyclistes
voltigeurs et bien les ministres
concernés avaient démissionné ce qui n'a
pas été le cas
dans cet épisode j'avais dit à l'époque
que je souhaitais la démission de
monsieur 15,9 je rappelle que je n'ai
pas été le seul à le dire est que je
n'ai pas été le seul à utiliser des mots
que j'ai utilisés dans ce discours je
plaide donc ma bonne foi je répondais à
quelqu'un qui m'a interpellé en disant
que j'allais mais j'aurais manqué à la
république et en lui ripostant que c'est
lui qui a manqué à la république dans la
mesure où il n'a pas assumé ce qui est
train de tradition dans notre pays
surtout quand un événement d'une telle
gravité se déroule ce n'est pas tout
monsieur 15 9 les l'homme qui a inventé
la technique de la mise en as des
manifestations qui ont débouché sur
d'innombrables violences pendant les
manifestations de la loi y compris je
veux dire ceci si monsieur 15,9 estime
qu'il est juste de me faire un procès en
diffamation eh bien je l'invite à le
faire de cette façon nous pourrons
devant un prétoire enfin prendre tous
les éléments toutes les pièces du
dossier des conditions dans lesquelles
rémy fraysse est mort et nous citerons
nous demanderons les témoignages des
journalistes qui ont fait des enquêtes
sur le sujet nous demanderons que
témoignent ceux qui se trouvaient sur
place et enfin il y aura un procès sur
les conditions dans lesquelles vanille
fraise est mort j'invite monsieur 15,9 à
la retenue et à ne pas utiliser un
extrait de discours pour se donner un
rôle et une importance que le parti
socialiste ne peut plus avoir en face de
la france insoumise voilà je souhaite
que d'une simple d'une manière ou d'une
autre chacun que ce soit dans les médias
ou que ce soit dans sur la scène
politique sur la scène politique on peut
admettre que des fois dans les discours
des uns des autres ou dans les répartit
le ton monte
après tout c'est une démocratie et la
polémique fait partie
figures habituelles delà de la
démocratie qui plus est quand cette
paroisse mère de balle si j'ose dire
mais j'invite à ce que on évite de s'en
prendre aux personnes comme on l'a fait
à mon sujet dans des termes sur
lesquelles je ne peux pas répondre parce
que je plante un journaliste dans une
matinale me traite de complotiste
comment voulez vous que je réponde que
dois je faire
quel est le leur aux gifs dans lequel je
peux répondre aux milliers de personnes
qui éventuellement ont entendu cette
accusation insensée quand un magazine
m'accuse de prades d'être une secte
parce que dans un enterrement
là où d'autres récite des prières
émouvantes parfois avec toute sorte
d'instrument nous ne mettons en chaîne
et nous chantons une chanson
révolutionnaire
comment voulez vous que je réponde et
comment puis-je des fins de l'honneur
des personnes qui se trouvaient là le
mien et celui de ceux de lettres que
nous avions perdre que nous avons perdus
et qu'ils me les six chaires comment
puis je répondre je vous adjure de me le
dire
doivent subir sans ne jamais rien dire
sauf à sitôt que je réplique devoir
subir les foudres de ceux dont c'est
l'intérêt de m'installer dans le paysage
comme un exagéré de manière à préparer
du mieux qu'ils peuvent un deuxième tour
dans lesquelles ils causent m'éliminer
non pour mes idées non pour celle de mes
amis mais pour une étiquette qu'il me ré
attribuées comme ça on ne vient la mode
nous traiter de sectes seulement parce
que nous sommes cohérents
est ce que nous n'avons pas un programme
est ce que nous n'avons pas recueilli 7
millions de voix est-ce que nous
participons pas tous les instants et les
grands moments de la vie démocratique du
pays
est-ce que nous avons jamais manqué à
nos devoirs pour défendre la liberté ou
combattre l'extrême droite
alors qu'est ce qui dans ma personne ou
dans 16 des gens qui m'entourent
justifie une telle wargnier qu'est ce
qui justifie une telle hargne pourquoi
sommes-nous pour chasser comme nous le
sommes
pourquoi acceptons qu'un humoriste
puisse mettre en cause mon porte parole
d'une manière aussi indignes à propos de
ses revenus ou de son appartement sans
que nous ayons une seule possibilité
pouvoir répliquer défendre notre honneur
et notre manière de vivre
enfin je souhaite donc et je demande
poliment respectueusement avec déférence
à tous ceux dont c'est la tâche de
défendre la sacro sainte vérité
médiatique
vous demande lâché nous arrêter nous à
nous agresser sur nos personnes
intéressées vous à ce que nous disons
que nous proposons à notre programme à
notre campagne mais laisser nos
personnes no more et nos familles en
dehors des vindictes que vous portez
contre nous vraiment je ne sais comment
exprimer mon indignation
si je le fais trop je suis accusée
d'être trop violent si je ne le fais pas
c'est la porte ouverte à tous les abus
pour qu'il continue je demande une trêve
une trêve médiatique dans l'injure
contre moi contre les miens je demande
qu'on puisse parler de ce qui nous
oppose réellement je ne suis pas séparer
de monsieur macron par des problèmes de
personne je le suis par des problèmes de
programme de faux et si le peuple
français lui donne raison et vedène
temps et bien je me soumettrai et albert
je suis sûr qu'ils en feraient autant et
c'est tout ce qui compte dans une
démocratie que l'on soit capable
d'accepter de gagner et d'assumer ou de
perdre et de l'assumer également ça
n'empêchera pas évidemment plus dans
cette hypothèse mon combat continuerai
voilà j'espère n'avoir pas mis trop de
flammes dans cette conclusion mais bon
je suis comme je suis on va pas me
changer je suis un méridional et c'est
comme ça bon avec votre permission
j'enlève ma veste
monsieur si vous voulez bien vous
asseoir comme tout le monde ça me ferait
très plaisir
sinon je ne vous répondrai pas annoncé
la chaîne
oui il ya un ordre apparemment vous
voyez j'ai déjà tout le monde de s'y
soumettre
on obéit nous demande pas de virer ces
deux bouts monsieur si ça vous fait
plaisir
non mais mettez vous debout salaire vous
faire plaisir mettez vous debout salaire
me faire plaisir je vous ai invités page
ou pas demandé de veiller au bon c'est
bon allez au suivant non mais si c'est
pour créer un incident ça c'est bon là
on a bon d'accord si vous entends bien
vous voulez remettre le fond au coeur de
cette campagne qui c'est possible mais
c'est vous qui avez lancé cette
polémique est sur quoi sur monsieur k
est-ce que vous la regrettée simplement
ce que j'en suis pas d'accord c'était ça
bon alors non monsieur je n'ai pas à
lancer ces polémiques
ces jeunes ont non non non non non non
j'ai fait 11 fois en discours sur le
code du travail et les conditions de la
rentrée scolaire et l'éducation
nationale et à l'occasion d'un de ses
discours
pendant une seconde d'écart j'ai répondu
à quelqu'un que j'ai pris comme figure
emblématique de l'accusation minette
d'après laquelle nous n'aurions pas
donné le concours de consigne de vote
entre les deux tours de l'élection
présidentielle et je voulais rappeler
pour les gens qui étaient là que cette
est absolument injuste puisque nous
avons appelé à ce qu'il n'y ait pas une
seule voie pour madame le pen je ne
faisais que rectifier et je trouvais
insupportable de me faire donner des
leçon de république par quelqu'un qui ne
sait pas lui-même astreint à la règle
minimale d'un ministre de la république
d'assumer les actes de l'administration
surtout quand ceux-ci ont débouché sur
un homicide
voilà c'est tout je n'ai pas provoqué
cette polémique je n'ai pas voulu de
cette polémique
ce n'est pas mon sujet c'est monsieur
15,9 qu'il a lancé en se saisissant
d'une phrase ont ils estimé qu'elle
était de nature à provoquer un intérêt
pour lui et qui maintenant est en train
de découvrir que remettre sur la scène
cette histoire de la mort de rémy france
n'était pas spécialement une
recommandation pour le parti socialiste
voilà c'est tout mais je n'ai pas
déclencher cette polémique je n'ai pas
souhaité et je ne la souhaite pas oui
bonjour licata
je remarque aujourd'hui vous parler
d'homicide la poudre aux précédents vous
avez parlé d' assassinats extra tendre
l'atmosphère mais risque vous soumet ce
que vous assumez toujours le fait que
c'était un assassinat et donc qu'il est
prêt midi je parle là en ce moment je
parle d' homicide
voilà l j'estime que c'est assez dit
pour aujourd'hui sur le sujet alors
après quel était votre question est ce
que je la devançais vous parle non à
l'interview répondre à votre question
qui est passionnante parce que vous
savez ce qui se passe aujourd'hui à
quinze jours du premier tour
les gens se demandent était ce un
assassinat prémédité mais enfin écoutez
un peu de sérieux
un peu de respect vous peut être un
accident a eu lieu dont le démarrage ou
un homicide ça peut être un accident un
assassinat ça suppose qu'ils me voilà
monsieur vous avez tout compris c'est
pourquoi je parle d' homicide et si vous
en voulez davantage
je n'accuse pas monsieur cazeneuve
d'être venu lui même assassiner
quelqu'un enfin de grâce quoi vous savez
pas ce qu'est un meeting vous ne savez
pas ce qu'est un discours qui dure trois
quarts d'heure vous ne savez pas ce
qu'est une réplique non il faut que vous
vous concentriez là-dessus à propos
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de cette
histoire de c est chez vous en foutez où
la paire histoire parce que vous les
journalistes vous êtes exemple il faut
30% à la base alors affaire suivante
eerdekens d'avoir c'est pas bref c'est
quoi votre votre truc à la base où nous
c'est 20 % l'abattement de base ou 10%
comme ça là vous ricanez mais quand même
c'est un peu la forme allongée
hervé kempf de l'or mais franchement à
quoi question mais c'est bien ce que je
vous dis ça vous fera moins mal à vous
je sais bien que ça arrive d'avoir est
classé g mais ça a à voir avec le revenu
à les vétérans m'écoutais je vous
attendais monsieur excusez moi j'ai pas
envie de me discuter avec vous quoi
alors donc essayons de faire en sorte
qu'on puisse avoir un échange d'une
licence si vous ne vous voyez bien qu'on
pouvait pas passer un point de presse a
parlé de monsieur 15,9 et d'une seconde
d'écart dans un discours à quelqu'un qui
me dit vous provoquer une polémique
alors que je me la fait infliger c'est
quand même ça la règle était à l'issue
de ce qu'elle est ce que dans le
contexte qui fait shooter effectivement
que vous avez rappelé où monsieur 15,9 a
été ministre de l'intérieur a donc que
la responsabilité d'un certain nombre de
façons de gérer l'ordre de maintenir
l'ordre que demain il y a un rapport
d'amnesty international très critique
sur l'évolution du droit de manifester
en france
est ce que vous ne pensez pas que le
procès dont vous menacent ce monsieur
cazeneuve ne serait pas à l'occasion en
fait de faire la lumière sur les
circonstances qui ont conduit à la mort
de rémy fraysse alors que le juge
d'instruction à toulouse et juge
d'instruction s'apprête à clore la faire
et que justement le procès que propose
monsieur cazenave permettrait de faire
la vérité et sur ce qui s'est passé
autour de monsieur frêche et sur les
conditions de maintien de l'ordre en
france monsieur qu'un peu c'est
évidemment au point de vue sur le moment
j'étais stupéfait honnêtement je vais
pas le cacher j'étais stupéfait et je
n'avais pas envie de cette polémique
je n'ai pas cherché ce que je voulais
c'était clore la tentation de me mettre
en cause et je demande qu'on comprenne
que je me sens
agressé donc lorsqu'on mis en cause mes
sentiments républicains
c'est peut-être parce que je les
montrerai que c'est devenu un jeu
maintenant pour certains de sans cesse
m'interpeller sur le sujet et puis
disons que la semaine a été rude pour ce
qui est de nos affects et de bon ça a
été rude de bien des façons parce que
beaucoup d'entre nous nous sommes des
hommes et des femmes de lutte de combat
et quand vous avez l'impression que vous
êtes comme un animal pris au piège qui
ne peut pas se défendre parce que les
coups pleuvent et vous n'avez aucun des
moyens de réponse
bon c'est clair que ça n'est pas le
moral et puis hier entre en moi même
comme on commençait déjà à me poser des
questions sur 15 9 une affaire qu'il me
déborde complètement j'ai réfléchi et
j'ai pris contact avec mes amis dans le
grand sud ouest pour savoir comment le
ressentez cette affaire et beaucoup ont
dit et bien que vienne le procès en
diffamation parce que précisément c'est
la seule occasion qu'on a d'amener
devant un prétoire cette affaire-là et
donc d'inviter à témoigner tous ceux qui
ont enquêté sur cette affaire et alors
on verra quand en effet monsieur 15,9 et
l'homme qui a mis en place une méthode
des méthodes d'intervention d'une
violence extrême dans les manifestants
d' al ol kainry se souviennent
parfaitement avec eux comment dire tous
les débordements auxquels a donné lieu
se donner lieu ce type de technique
notamment les nas qui était une
nouveauté qu'on ne connaissait pas dans
le cas du barrage de siemens il a été
établi que des grenades offensives
avaient été utilisés et que le
commandement de l'opération sur le
terrain s'était déroulé en dehors de la
présence de tout civil ce qui rend la
forme de l'intervention il légal dans du
point de vue qui est celui de la loi en
france par conséquent je ne crois pas
que monsieur cazeneuve est à gagner à ce
procès mais tout compte fait je trouve
que
il pourrait être utile à ce que éclater
la vérité surtout que ce soit en quelque
sorte dissuasif pour les suivants c'est
à dire que comme ceux qui s'attendent à
la victoire de monsieur macron certains
d'affaires des fermes et leurs méthodes
ils doivent s'attendre également à ce
qu'il y ait une réplique sociale et je
ne voudrais pas qu'elle se déroule dans
les conditions dans lesquelles s'est
déroulé tout le tout la scène indé loi
elle comment ils donc je dis
tranquillement ce qui doit être dit je
suis d'accord pour requalifier
d'homicide et je prie qu'on comprenne
que dans invité in de trois quarts
d'heure il peut arriver qu'un mot ne
soit pas calibré exactement comme la
presse elle nous habitue à calibrer les
mots très exactement avec précision et
soins et donc voila quoi monsieur oui
bon d'accord on a compris à vous madame
mais monsieur écoutez vous devez
comprendre que les mots sont importants
en effet comme quelqu'un meurt et que un
dispositif a été mis en place on peut
penser qu'il s'agit d'un homicide et pas
d'un accident de la route
d'ailleurs des accidents de la route
sont considérés comme des homicides je
ne vois pas quoi vous voulez arriver à
quoi vous voulez arriver monsieur non
alors oui si l'on savait pas taisez-vous
c'est aussi bien voilà c'est ça et vous
écoutez monsieur c'est bon je vous ai
déjà répondu j'ai raconté dans quelles
conditions avait lieu mon discours j'ai
dit comment j'avais utilisé mes mots
j'ai dit ce que je viens de dire il me
semble que c'est assez maintenant
peut-être que vous aspirerez le mettre
un sac de centre sur la tête que je me
flagelle parce que vous vous prenez pour
des juges vous êtes juste en journalisme
monsieur rappelez-vous le d'accord donc
vous devriez vous poser la question de
savoir comment ils feraient ces morts au
lieu de venir me demander des comptes à
moi
moralisation politique exacte on a le
sentiment que c'est de plus en plus
compliqué le monde publie nouvelles
révélations sur richard ferrand cet
après-midi sur les conflits d'intérêts
est ce que le gouvernement pour apporter
cette loi et si vous avez un groupe
comment est ce que vous comptez l'amendé
écoutez si il y à de nouvelles
révélations qui font apparaître que les
conflits d'intérêts se multiplient la
seule chose qu'on a à dire c'est que
c'est une bonne idée de les empêcher
bon alors je sais que monsieur tagro a
pris contact avec eux avec une équipe
pour que je le rencontre puisqu'il
rencontre tout le monde j'ai à dire sur
le sujet évidemment alors je commence
par ça si vous voulez avant d'entrer peu
plus en détails que je ne connais pas à
cette heure mais la moralisation de la
vie publique
c'est le point numéro deux du programme
l'avenir en commun point numéro un la
réforme des institutions pour un numéro
2 la la séparation de l'état et de
l'argent d'accord sur ce point
et pour faire bref et sans entrer trop
dans les détails
d'abord notre position numéro un c'est
de couper des circuits qui rendent
possible la triche la fraude je parle
pas pour l'instant des conflits
d'intérêts encore que le conflit
d'intérêts
neuf fois sur dix conduit à une
utilisation il faut faire attention à
chaque mot parce que sinon monsieur
venir la semaine prochaine
interrogé sur la gravité de ce que je
prône en disant que quand la loi n'est
pas très stable les contournements sont
amplifiées les contournements conduisent
toujours à se mettre soit en dehors de
la morale soit en dehors de la loi bref
c'est par rapport aux paradis fiscaux
que notre attention est la plus
concentrée en effet ces paradis fiscaux
sont le moyen par lequel la fronde peut
prendre toute son ampleur et je veux à
cette occasion attirer votre attention
sur le fait que quelqu'un d'autre me
fait un procès on aura sans doute
d'autres maintenant c'est à la mode
c'est la société générale qui elle aussi
me fait un procès en diffamation pour
avoir dit c'est un beau très grave que
son président monsieur ou des amants
thèse qui est un mot très grave en effet
monsieur oudéa a déclaré devant une
commission d enquête parlementaire après
avoir juré de dire la vérité toute la
vérité qu'il n'y avait aucune activité
de la société générale dans le paradis
fiscal c'est la sphère des panamas
peppers et donc à cette occasion j'avais
dit qu'il mentait
j'étais pas le seul d'ailleurs à l'avoir
dit et ça nous vaut un an après je ne
sais pas pourquoi un an après peut-être
parce que ces gens se sentent
aujourd'hui désert il pense que
l'environnement politique leur est
favorable à un procès en diffamation
fort bien et bien là aussi ce sera un
procès intéressant parce qu'on aura
l'occasion de mettre à plat
comment fonctionnent les circuits de la
société générale et comment ça
fonctionne et que le panama pépère
honnêtement pour nous c'est quand même
là qu'est le coeur de la difficulté
aujourd'hui ses 85 milliards de fraude
fiscale
réponse et interdiction pour les banques
françaises de travailler dans les
paradis fiscaux
réponse et la déclaration d'impôt
universel pour tous les citoyens
français réponse et la nécessité pour
chaque entreprise le déclarer ses
revenus dans le pays dans lequel dans
lequel il les réalise
etc etc ces points sont rappelés dans la
revue de presse quant aux conflits
d'intérêts il va de soi que il ya quand
même de la part des des responsables un
peu de jugeote à avoir quoi franchement
clairement si vous mettez un ancien
lobbyiste d'une entreprise dans un
ministère
que voulez vous il n'ya pas besoin
d'internet pour comprendre qu'il va y
avoir un problème
1 c'est d'ailleurs la pratique et même
du lobbyisme qui devrait être discuté
dans notre pays est ce que on trouve ça
aussi normal que les nord-américains
pour le trouver
ou que les institutions européennes
peuvent le trouver pour ma part je ne
crois pas et je rappelle que pour qu'il
y ait des corons plus faux des
corrupteurs pour que y est quand il ya
conflit d'intérêts ça veut donc bien
dire qu'il ya des intérêts qui sont en
jeu et pas simplement des postures
personnel vous aurez la surprise lorsque
vous ferez le travail auquel nous nous
sommes livrés qui consiste à passer en
revue la biographie d'un certain nombre
de gens qu'ils soient membres des
cabinets ministériels ou qu'ils soient
des candidats à la députation de
découvrir que certains ont effacé leur
page facebook
certains ont effacé des archives de leur
tri
une qu'ils avaient publié dans tel ou
tel journal et je vous laisse le plaisir
de les rechercher même je crois que nous
aimons la piste est un ou deux ainsi que
les gens qui ne publient pas leurs noms
complets de manière à ce qu'on perde
leur trace et ainsi de suite
alors voila si monsieur si j'arrive à
faire coïncider mon emploi du temps est
vraiment je demande à monsieur bayrou ne
pas le prendre mal
si c'était quelqu'un d'autre de mon
entourage qui va le voir s'il n'y a
aucune marque d intérêt pour la question
ou pour sa personne c'est simplement que
mon emploi du temps est abominable et
que le plaisir d'aller lui dire ce qui
est écrit dans le dans le programme
l'avenir ans comme un autre que moi
pourrait le faire mais je vais tout
faire pour y aller moi même d'autant que
sur le plan humain j'apprécie le
monsieur bayrou et je sais que de toute
façon même si nous sommes pas d'accord
et nous ne sommes pas d'accord
eh bien les changera de bonne qualité
oui où je veux lui dire une chose
mon cher françois bayrou si vous voulez
qu'il y ait de bons juges dans le pays
fait confiance au peuple
la mesure qui à prendre parmi toutes les
autres c'est de donner au peuple le
pouvoir de révoquer ces élus et ça c'est
très facile à faire et vous verrez que
le peuple est un bon gardien de ses
intérêts bonjour monsieur mélenchon à
l'accent pérou la scène parlementaire
vous parliez tout à l'heure de vous
vos ambitions pour les élections
législatives vous parliez de 78
circonscription dans lesquelles il était
proche de 18 % soit 1 18% pardon de
l'endroit où vous pourriez être au
second tour objectivement qu'elle sait à
quel nombre de sièges vous vous attendez
à l'issue de ces élections législatives
qu'est ce que vous voulez je vous dise
et 289 la majorité donc tu aspires à 289
la vérité vraie ultime c'est que
personne n'arrive à chiffrer quoi que ce
soit parce que les repères précédent ne
fonctionne pas par exemple dans un
deuxième tour où nous opposerions à un
candidat macro nice thomas crown ya je
ne sais pas comme on dit personne n'est
capable de dire en quoi consiste
réellement les reports de voix c'est à
dire est-ce que massivement tous les
gens de droite se mettent à voter pour
le maquereau nhien tous les socialistes
pour ou de bien ce que ça se partage
dans quelle proportion les observateurs
sont incapables de le dire
donc on travaille sur deux bases la
première c'est la projection des
résultats de la présidentielle en
sachant que c'est une projection qui est
fragile ou au moins pour une raison qui
devrait porter certains analystes à la
prudence
c'est que il y a moins de candidats
présentés par la république en marche
qu'il n'y en a de la france insoumise
bon ils sont pas présents dans toutes
les circonscriptions et vous verrez qu'à
la fin c'est à dire hors colmant finale
vous n'avez pas d'étiquette majorité
présidentielle par conséquent ça va être
la grande tambouille à la sortie de tout
ça parce que des gens vont être pas en
majorité présidentielle entre les deux
tours qui n'y sont pas au premier vous
savez qu'il ya un grand nombre de
circonscriptions où il ya plusieurs
candidats qui se réclament de la
majorité présidentielle hier soir
j'étais à evry en plus de monsieur
valls y en a nous tu crois et puis là à
côté le pareil en a un ou deux et à
chaque fois il ya plusieurs candidats
donc ce qui est à peu près certain c'est
qu'entre les deux tours des gens vont se
déclarer membres de la majorité
présidentielle qui ne rompt pas dit aux
premiers thouars qu'est ce que ça donne
tout ça en ciel personne n'en sait rien
et donc je suis bien embarrassé pour
vous répondre
il ya des jours où je suis au sommet la
féliciter parce qu'on m'amène du paquet
de circonscriptions qu'on a gagné le
lendemain on me dit qu'il ya eu un
sondage moins bon et des alarmistes fond
du seau sanctionne partout je ne sais
pas vous répondre monsieur ce que je
sais c'est que la situation tout mon
raisonnement est basé là dessus d'accord
je me suis trompé quelquefois c'est
clair mais je me suis quand même pas
trop trompé sur ce que j'ai pu dire sur
le dégage isme et je pense que le dégage
il va prendre des tournures assez
spécial au moment de ces élections
législatives
voilà par la force des choses c'est
comme ça on le sort dans le pays
1 les gens n'ont pas fait tout ce qu'ils
ont fait pendant cette élection
présidentielle pour le seul plaisir de
reconduire les riques du passé je ne le
crois pas après bon bah voilà je suis
comme vous un c'est la vie qui va
trancher puis j'observerai et ma culture
politique sans doute va faire un bond en
avant après des épisodes aussi
stupéfiant que ce que nous avons vécu
madame baisse des molières peut-être qui
a levé la main bonjour a fait le buzz et
miliaires du monde sur la sphère richard
ferrand est ce que vous estimez que
cette situation est encore tenable au
gouvernement écoutez je suis bien
embarrassée parce que je suis comme tout
le monde c'est à dire j'ouvre le journal
j'apprends des rebondissements je vois
bien que ça sent la carabistouilles
cette affaire bon bah nan mais c'est
l'avocat qui a dit ce qu'ils avaient à
dire honnêtement j ai pas pensé mais je
n'ai pas vu où est l arnaque au début
bon j'étais comme tout le monde à dire
ah bah oui quand même
après tout un contrat bout mais ce sont
des affaires privées du gouvernement
alors vous essayer de pas être vous
essayer de pas être une brute quoi donc
vous réfléchissez vous savez bien que la
polémique des fois peut conduire un peu
plus loin puis l'avocat il fait la
réponse qu'il dit mais au lieu de faire
tout ça ils n'avaient qu'à acheter eux
directement
et dans ce cas-là ça oui c'est vrai je
me suis dis bah c'est vrai c'est
vraiment une arnaque
bon alors voilà c'est ma ma conversion
est récente
sa dalle d'hier et d'avoir lu le journal
le parisien et d'avoir lu alors
peut-être que je vais à grains qui
sourit parce qu'ils sont plus malins que
moi mais moi j'ai pas vu larnack au
départ je me disais c'est un procédé un
peu grossier bon alors à partir de là
franchement moi ça m'arrange qui reste
cloué sur sa croire hein parce que
imaginer qu'il ne dégage on n'aurait
plus rien à dire pendant les dix
prochains jours pour plein de gens donc
là pendant dix jours ça nous laisse une
excellente vitrine du maquereau nice
muriel le numéro un le gars qui a tout
organisé et qui a pris des grandeurs
pour dire que dorénavant ça serait plus
comme auparavant et comme on allait voir
ce qu'on allait voir
le résultat c'est que c'est lui qui se
fait prendre la main dans le pot bon
pour nous c'est pas le plus mauvais cas
ce qu'on souhaite pas par contre c'est
qu'on recommence le cirque du costard de
fillon pendant quinze jours quoi et
qu'on soit pendant quinze jours tous à
se gratter la tête sur le fonctionnement
du crédit mutuel de bretagne et combien
vous
m² loués bon il ya des sujets plus
palpitant mais vous avez raison de dire
que s'il fallait pas jouer les
chevaliers blancs
si la cape était pas aussi blanche que
ce qu'il en avait dit voilà mais bon ça
fait nous à faire c'est comme le procès
15 noeuds c'est une bonne chose a fait
réfléchir ça montre que les gens qui se
croient très malins ne sont pas autant
qu'ils ont dans l'air annoncé une radio
j'aimerais revenir seulement sur les
décalages et 15 noeuds ce matin sur
france inter qui vous demandent de fait
verser vos excuses
qu'est ce que vous avez envie de tir par
rapport à ça vous fait vos excuses quoi
il dit oui j'ai vu ça il dit qu'il
retirerait son sa menace de procès en
diffamation mais entre temps mes amis
m'ont tous téléphoner alerté qu'il ya un
nombre considérable de gens que ce
procès en diffamation intéresse alors
bon moi je ne veux pas je suis pas 15 9
je ne prends pas un air de notaire de
province ou de blu du curé pour agresser
les autres monsieur cazeneuve dit de moi
que j'ai manqué à la république et que
je n'ai pas pris position contre
l'extrême droite
c'est un menteur et il le fait dans
l'intention de me nuire
sur une allégation qui est calomnieuse
mais moi je ne veux pas le calomnier
donc si dans un discours
un mot a paru excessifs que comme on
vient de me le rappeler à l'instant
compte tenu de la définition du mot ce
mot n'est pas adapté à ce que je veux
dire
je suis prêt à en utiliser un autre
voyez-vous quand je faisais du matin
avant que le gouvernement a interdit il
y avait un cas de traduction c'était cas
les harpons thème fecit ce qui veut dire
ouf et site si vous voulez césar fait un
pont alors on interpeller nos jeunes
l'intelligence et on nous disait
croyez-vous cesare fait lui même le pont
alors non alors on nous disait on ne
doit pas traduire césar cette info on
traduit césar a fait faire un pont voilà
alors dans le cas qui nous occupe
je crois que le mot homicide est plus
adapté à décrire ce que je veux ce que
je voulais mettre en cause c'est à dire
que cet homme n'a pas assumé la
responsabilité qui était la sienne et en
chef de son administration c'était à lui
d'assumer la situation
notamment usage de grenades offensives
dans les conditions dans lesquelles cela
a été fait et que c'était totalement
injuste d'imputer le gendarme qui
attirait cette grenade
parce que il l'a fait dans le cadre d'un
ordre qui lui avait été donné et que la
chaîne du commandement il a été établi
assez clairement par le reportage de
reporter que je vous invite à lire c'est
un gros phares vous pouvez pas dire que
c'est moi qui écris et il n'est pas
toujours favorable des fois il m'est
très défavorable alors par conséquent on
peut considérer que on peut s'appuyer
sur cette enquête et pour pas le gêner
je dirais qu'il ya eu d'autres enquêtes
de fait sur le moment même et autour de
plusieurs journaux qui ont montré qu'il
y avait une situation qui n'était pas
normal que donc c'est aux responsables
politiques d'en assumer donc je veux
dire que celui qui me fait la leçon de
république doit commencer par balayer
devant sa porte
tante lui était au pied du mur et n'a
pas assumé sa responsabilité
républicaine
tu t'étais de démissionner dans cette
circonstance voilà et à l'époque je les
dis et j'ai pas été le seul
1 donc si monsieur 15,9 soit une
amnistie pour ça faut qu est d'abord un
procès alors s'il ya un procès en
diffamation et bien j'irai au procès en
diffamation
je plaiderai la bonne foi et
j'expliquerai le sens des mots que j'ai
utilisés ce qu'il vaut mieux utiliser je
pense qu'il vaut mieux parler d'homicide
à 7 heures et je propose un monsieur 15
9 on en reste là
mais s'il veut faire un procès en
diffamation qu'est ce que je vous disais
bien j'irai moi je me sauve pas quand il
ya des procès et quand je suis convoqué
la preuve je suis convoqué par le juge
pour la société générale et ben j'y vais
et en attendant d'en faire la fête à la
société générale vendredi et samedi
prochain pour qu'elle se souvient bien
qu'avec nous il n'y a pas de coût sans
riposte j'ai pas dis à vous drôle à un
copain
et après chacun son imagination
la dernière fois des on a été distribuer
des biscuits pour expliquer aux clients
de la société générale à quel genre de
banque qu'ils appartenaient alors il ya
des gens que ça choque tout ça on fait
des choses comme ça dépend car des
affiches où on demande à nos amis dans
chaque ville d'aller devant la société
générale naturellement on le fait
pacifiquement à je m'empresse de dire et
c'est pas la peine de nous tirer des
grenades offensives
parce qu'après ça devenus des
circonstances que les mots peine à
décrire
c'est tout ça y est à l'infini bon alors
je me suis fait entouré de deux
personnes tout à fait compétente de
s'exprimer monsieur eric coquerel que
vous richie porte parole monsieur
corbières et à la rude tâche de me
représenter dans d'innombrables
circonstances d'embarras